Ce que je vais faire, dans l'esprit de création collaborative
c'est simplement répéter nombre des points
que les trois personnes avant moi ont déjà formulés.
Mais faîtes cela --
Ceci s'appelle collaboration créative
en fait, cela s'appelle un emprunt.
Mais faites le selon une perspective particulière
et c'est s'interroger sur le rôle des utilisateurs et des consommateurs
dans ce monde émergeant
de la collaboration créative
dont Jimmy et les autres ont parlé.
Laissez-moi, pour commencer, vous poser
cette simple question:
qui a inventé le V.T.T ?
Parce que la théorie économique traditionnelle dirait,
que le V.T.T. a probablement été inventé par un gros fabriquant de vélos
qui a un gros laboratoire de R&D
dans lequel ils réfléchissaient à de nouveaux projets
et il en est sorti ça. Cela ne vient pas de là.
Une autre réponse pourrait être, que cela vient d'une sorte de génie solitaire
travaillant dans son garage,
qui, en travaillent sur diverses sortes de vélo, en est arrivé
à un vélo, comme tombé du ciel.
Cela ne vient pas de là. Le V.T.T.
vient des utilisateurs, de jeunes utilisateurs,
plus spécifiquement, un groupe en Caroline du Nord
qui étaient frustrés par les vélos de course traditionnels,
cette sorte de vélo qu'utilisait Eddy Merckx
ou votre grand frère, et ils sont très glamours.
Mais ils étaient aussi frustrés par les vélos que votre père utilise
ceux qui ont un grand guidon comme ça, et qui étaient trop lourds.
Alors ils ont pris le cadre de ces grands vélos,
les ont assemblés avec les équipements des vélos de course,
ont récupéré des freins de moto,
et ont plus ou moins mélangé et assemblé divers ingrédients.
Et pour les premières, je ne sais pas, trois ou cinq années de leur vie,
les V.T.T. furent connus sous le nom de "guimbarde".
Et ils étaient juste fabriqués au sein d'une communauté de cyclistes,
principalement en Caroline du Nord.
Et alors, une de ces sociétés qui importait des pièces détachées
pour les "guimbardes" a décidé de monter un business,
ont commencé à les vendre à d'autres personnes
et progressivement, une autre société émergea de cela, Marin,
et c'était probablement, je ne sais pas,
10 ou peut-être même 15 ans,
avant que les grosses sociétés
ne réalisent qu'il y avait un marché.
30 ans plus tard,
les ventes de V.T.T.
et d'équipement pour V.T.T.
représentent 65% des ventes de vélo aux États-Unis.
Cela représente 58 millions de dollars.
C'est une catégorie entièrement créée par des consommateurs,
qui n'aurait pas été créée par le marché traditionnel des vélos
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas voir le besoin,
l'opportunité;
Ils n'avaient pas d'incitation à innover.
La seule chose avec laquelle je ne suis pas d'accord
au sujet de la présentation de Yochai,
c'est lorsqu'il dit qu'internet rend possible
cette capacité distributive pour l'innovation.
C'est lorsque internet est combiné
à ce genre de consommateurs passionnés semi-professionnels --
qui ont les connaissances, ils ont une incitation à innover,
ils ont les outils, ils ont la volonté --
que vous obtenez ce genre d'explosion
de création collaborative.
Et de là, vous obtenez un besoin pour le genre de choses
dont Jimmy parlait, et qui correspond à nos nouveaux types d'organisation,
ou, une meilleure façon de le dire:
comment nous organisons-nous sans organisation ?
Ceci est maintenant possible, vous n'avez pas besoin d'organisation pour vous organiser,
pour réaliser des tâches grandes et complexes,
comme créer de nouveaux logiciels.
Ainsi, c'est un énorme challenge
à la façon dont nous concevons la créativité.
La vue traditionnelle, toujours étroitement mêlée
à l'idée que nous nous faisons de la créativité
-- dans les organisations, dans les gouvernements --
est que la créativité concerne des personnes spécifiques :
casquette de base-ball à l'envers,
qui viennent a des conférences comme celle-ci, dans des endroits spéciaux,
des universités d'élite, des laboratoires de R&D dans la forêt ou sous l'eau
peut-être des locaux un peu spéciaux, peints de toutes les couleurs,
vous savez, des poufs, peut-être un baby-foot.
Des gens spéciaux, des endroits spéciaux, imaginant des idées spéciales,
vous avez alors un tuyau qui amène les idées
directement vers les consommateurs, qui attendent passivement.
Ils peuvent dire "oui" ou "non" à l'invention;
C'est l'idée que nous nous faisons de la créativité.
Quelle est la politique qui en découle
si vous êtes au gouvernement ou si vous dirigez une grosse société?
Plus de gens spéciaux, plus d'endroits spéciaux.
Construire des pôles de créativité dans les villes;
Créer plus de centres de R&D, et ainsi de suite.
Elargir les tuyaux vers les consommateurs.
Et bien cette vue, je pense, est de plus en plus fausse.
Je pense qu'elle a toujours été fausse,
parce que je pense que la créativité a toujours été hautement collaborative.
et elle a probablement été largement interactive.
Mais c'est de plus en plus faux, et une des raisons pour lesquelles c'est faux
est que les idées remontent dans le tuyau.
Les idées remontent des consommateurs,
et ils sont souvent en avance sur les producteurs.
Pourquoi cela?
Et bien un problème
est que les innovations radicales,
lorsque vous avez des idées
qui affectent un grand nombre de technologies ou de personnes,
ont une grande part d'incertitude.
Les retours sur investissements de l'innovation sont plus grands
lorsque l'incertitude est plus grande.
Et quand vous avez une innovation radicale,
Très souvent, l'application est très incertaine.
Toute l'histoire de la téléphonie
est celle de la gestion de cette incertitude.
Les toutes premières lignes téléphoniques terrestres,
les inventeurs pensaient
qu'elles seraient utilisées par les gens pour écouter
des rediffusions en live
des concerts de la côte Ouest.
Lorsque les sociétés de téléphonie mobile ont inventé le SMS,
ils n'avaient aucune idée de ce qu'ils allaient en faire;
ce n'est que lorsque la technologie est arrivée dans les mains
des utilisateurs adolescents
qu'ils en ont inventé l'utilisation.
Ainsi, plus l'innovation est radicale,
et plus l'incertitude est grande;
et plus il faut innover dans l'utilisation
pour exploiter une technologie.
Tous nos brevets, toute notre approche
des brevets et de l'invention, est basée sur l'idée
que l'inventeur sait à quoi va servir une invention;
que l'on sait à quoi cela va servir.
De plus en plus, les inventeurs
ne seront plus capables de le dire à l'avance.
On le réalisera à l'usage,
en collaboration avec des utilisateurs.
Nous aimons à penser que l'invention est
une sorte de moment de création:
il y a comme une naissance lorsque quelqu'un découvre une idée.
La vérité, c'est que la plupart de la créativité
est cumulative et collaborative.
Comme wikipedia, cela se développe sur une longue période.
La seconde raison pour laquelle les utilisateurs sont de plus en plus importants
c'est qu'ils sont la source de grandes innovations perturbatrices.
Si vous voulez trouver les prochaines grandes idées,
c'est souvent difficile de les trouver sur les marchés dominants,
dans les grandes organisations.
Et regardez seulement à l'intérieur de grandes organisations
et vous comprendrez pourquoi.
Imaginez, vous êtes dans une grande société ;
vous êtes évidemment enthousiastes à l'idée de grimper dans la hiérarchie.
Allez-vous voir le comité de direction pour dire
"regardez, j'ai une idée fantastique
pour un produit embryonnaire
sur un marché marginal,
avec des consommateurs auxquels nous n'avons jamais eu à faire face,
et je ne suis pas sûr que ça va marcher, mais ça pourrait être vraiment énorme dans le futur" ?
Non, ce que vous faites, c'est que vous y allez, et vous dites,
J'ai une idée fantastique pour une innovation incrémentale
d'un produit existant que nous vendons déjà via des canaux existants
à des utilisateurs existants, et je peux garantir
que vous en tirerez tel retour sur investissement sur les trois prochaines années.
Les grosses sociétés ont une tendance intrinsèque
à renforcer les succès passés.
Ils ont déjà tellement investit dedans,
que c'est très difficile pour eux de repérer
des marchés émergeant. Ainsi, les nouveaux marchés émergeant
sont le terrain de prédilection pour les utilisateurs passionnés.
Le meilleur exemple:
qui dans l'industrie musicale,
il y a 30 ans, aurait dit,
"oui, inventons une forme de musique
avec des noirs dépossédés
dans des ghettos, qui expriment leur frustration sur le monde
par le biais d'une forme de musique
que beaucoup de gens trouvent à priori relativement difficile à écouter.
Ça a tout l'air d'être un futur hit, allons-y."
(rires)
Et que se passe-t-il? La musique Rap est créée par les utilisateurs.
Ils la produisent sur leur propres cassettes, avec leur propre matériel d'enregistrement;
ils la distribuent eux-mêmes.
30 ans plus tard,
le rap est la forme dominante de musique de la culture populaire --
cela ne serait jamais venu des grandes entreprises.
Elle doit être initiée -- c'est le troisième point --
par ces professionnels-amateurs.
c'est la phrase que j'ai utilisée
dans diverses choses que j'ai faites
avec un groupe de réflexion à Londres, qui s'appelle Demos,
alors que nous observions ces gens qui sont des amateurs --
qui le font donc par passion --
mais ils veulent le faire avec une très haute exigence.
Et dans un champ très large de disciplines --
logiciel, astronomie,
sciences naturelles,
de grands pans des loisirs et de la culture
comme le kite-surfing, et ainsi de suite --
vous trouvez des gens qui veulent le faire parce qu'ils aiment ça,
mais ils veulent le faire avec énormément d'exigences.
Ils travaillent pour leur loisir, si vous voulez.
Ils prennent leur loisir très sérieusement:
ils acquièrent des compétences, ils investissent du temps,
ils utilisent une technologie de moins en moins chère, et pas seulement internet;
des appareils photos, des technologies de design,
de la technologie loisir, des planches de surf, etc..
En grande partie grâce à la mondialisation,
de nombreux équipements sont devenus bien plus accessibles.
Des consommateurs plus connaisseurs, mieux éduqués
plus capables de se connecter les uns aux autres,
plus capables de faire des choses ensemble.
La consommation, en ce sens, est une expression
de leur potentiel productif.
Nous avons découvert que la raison pour laquelle les gens s'intéressent à cela,
est qu'ils ne se sentent pas assez expressifs au travail.
Ils n'ont pas l'impression de faire quelque chose qui leur tient à cœur,
alors ils choisissent ce genre d'activité.
Ceci à d'énormes implications organisationnelles
pour de très larges pans de la vie.
Prenons comme exemple l'astronomie,
que Yochai a déjà mentionné.
Il y a 20 ou 30 ans,
seuls les grands astronomes professionnels
avec de très gros télescopes étaient capables de voir loin dans l'espace.
Et il y a un gros télescope au nord de l'Angleterre, appelé Jodrell Bank,
et quand j'étais enfant, c'était époustouflant,
parce que l'exploration lunaire démarrait, et cet engin se déplaçait sur des rails.
Et c'était gigantesque -- c'était absolument énorme.
Maintenant, six
astronomes amateurs, travaillant sur internet,
avec des télescopes de Dobson électroniques --
qui sont à peu près libres de droit --
avec quelques capteurs de lumière
développé ces 10 dernières années, et avec internet,
ils peuvent faire ce que Jodrell Bank pouvait faire de mieux il y a 30 ans.
Ainsi, en astronomie, vous avez cette vaste explosion
de nouvelles ressources productives.
Les utilisateurs peuvent être les producteurs.
Que cela veut-il alors dire,
pour notre paysage organisationnel?
Et bien, imaginez seulement un monde,
pour le moment, divisé en deux camps.
Ici, vous avez le vieux modèle traditionnel de l'entreprise.
Des gens spéciaux, des endroits spéciaux;
on brevète, on envoie le tout dans un tuyau
à des consommateurs majoritairement passifs et attentistes.
Là, imaginons que nous avons
Wikipedia, Linux, et au-delà -- l'open source.
Là c'est ouvert, ici c'est fermé;
ceci est nouveau, cela est traditionnel.
Et bien, la première chose que vous pouvez dire, je pense avec certitude,
c'est ce que Yochai a déjà dit --
il y a une grande lutte
entre ces deux formes d'organisation.
Ces gens ici vont faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour empêcher la réussite de ces organisations,
parce qu'elles les menacent.
Ainsi, le débat à propos
des droits d'auteur, des droits électroniques, et ainsi de suite --
tout ceci a pour but d'essayer d'étouffer, de mon point de vue,
ce genre d'organisations.
Ce que nous sommes en train de voir est une corruption complète
de l'idée de brevet et de droit d'auteur.
Destinés à servir de prime à l'inventivité,
censés être un moyen d'orchestrer la propagation de connaissance,
ils sont de plus en plus utilisés par de grandes sociétés
pour créer un mur de brevets
pour empêcher l'innovation.
Laissez-moi vous donner juste deux exemples.
Tout d'abord, imaginez-vous en train d'aller voir un investisseur
et de lui dire : "j'ai une idée fantastique.
J'ai inventé ce super nouveau programme
qui est bien bien mieux que Microsoft Outlook."
Quel investisseur censé va vous donner de l'argent pour monter une entreprise
concurrente de Microsoft, avec Microsoft Outlook? Personne.
C'est pour cela que toute compétition avec Microsoft doit venir --
et peut seulement venir --
d'un projet de type open source.
Ainsi, il y a un énorme argument compétitif
pour soutenir la capacité
de l'innovation issue des consommateurs et de l'open source,
car c'est un des plus puissants
leviers pour lutter contre le monopole.
Il y a aussi un énorme argument professionnel.
Parce que les professionnels, ici
dans ces organisations fermées --
ils peuvent êtres universitaires, ils peuvent être programmeurs,
ils peuvent être docteurs, ils peuvent être journalistes --
mon précédent métier --
disent, "Non, non -- vous ne pouvez pas faire confiance à ces gens là."
Quand j'ai commencé dans le journalisme --
Financial Times, il y a 20 ans --
c'était très très excitant
de voir quelqu'un en train de lire un journal.
Et vous regardiez par dessus son épaule dans le métro
pour voir s'il était en train de lire votre article.
En général, il était en train de regarder le prix des actions,
et le morceau de papier avec votre article
était par terre ou quelque chose dans le genre,
et vous savez, "Mon dieux, qu'est-il en train de faire!
Il n'est pas en train de lire mon brillant article!"
Et nous laissions à nos utilisateurs, les lecteurs,
deux endroits où ils pouvaient participer au journal:
la page des courriers, où ils pouvaient écrire une lettre,
et nous pouvions daigner, après l'avoir réduit de moitié
l'imprimer trois jours plus tard.
Et la tribune libre, sur laquelle ceux qui connaissent l'éditeur --
qui ont été a l'école avec lui, qui couchent avec sa femme --
peuvent écrire une contribution.
C'étaient les deux endroits.
Horreur: maintenant les lecteurs veulent être les auteurs et les éditeurs.
Ce n'est pas leur rôle; ils sont supposés lire ce que nous écrivons.
Mais ils ne veulent pas être journalistes. Les journalistes pensent
que les bloggueurs veulent être journalistes;
ils ne veulent pas être journalistes, ils veulent juste avoir une voix.
Ils veulent, comme Jimmy l'a dit, avoir un dialogue, une conversation.
Ils veulent prendre part au flot d'information.
Ce qui se passe ici est que l'ensemble du domaine
de la créativité s'étend.
Du coup, il va y avoir une énorme bataille.
Mais il va aussi y avoir un considérable mouvement
de l'ouvert vers le fermé.
Ce que vous allez voir, je pense, ce sont deux choses d'une importance critique,
et je pense que ce sont deux challenges
pour le mouvement de l'ouverture.
La première est:
pouvons-nous vraiment vivre du bénévolat?
Si c'est aussi critique,
n'avons-nous pas besoin qu'il soit financé, organisé, soutenu
de manière beaucoup plus structurée?
Je pense que l'idée de créer la croix-rouge
de l'information et de la connaissance est une idée fantastique,
mais pouvons nous réellement organiser cela, juste avec du bénévolat?
Comment adapter les politiques publiques
et les financements pour rendre cela possible?
Quel est le rôle de la BBC,
par exemple, dans ce monde?
Quel doit être le rôle des pouvoirs publics?
Et finalement, je pense que vous allez voir
les organisations fermées intelligentes
se déplacer de plus en plus vers l'ouverture.
Ainsi, il ne va pas s'agir d'une compétition entre deux camps,
mais il y aura toutes sortes d'intermédiaires intéressants
que les gens vont occuper.
De nouveaux modèles d'organisation vont émerger,
mélangeant ouverture et fermeture de manière délicate.
Ce ne sera plus aussi tranché; ce ne sera plus Microsoft contre Linux --
il y aura toutes sortes de choses entre les deux.
Et ces modèles d'organisation
s'avèrent incroyablement puissants,
et les gens qui peuvent les comprendre
vont vraiment bien réussir.
Laissez-moi juste vous donner un dernier exemple
de ce que cela signifie.
J'étais à Shanghai,
dans un immeuble de bureaux
construit sur ce qui était une rizière il y a cinq ans --
Un des 2500 gratte-ciels
qu'ils ont construit à Shanghai ces 10 dernières années.
Et je dînais avec cet homme, nommé Timothy Chen.
Timothy Chen a mis en place une activité sur internet
en 2000.
Il n'a pas continué sur internet, gardé son argent,
et décidé de faire des jeux vidéo.
Il dirige une société appelée Shanda,
qui est la plus grosse société de jeux vidéo en Chine.
9000 serveurs partout en Chine;
il a 250 millions d'abonnés.
A chaque instant, 4 millions de joueurs jouent à l'un de ses jeux.
Combien de personnes emploie-t-il
pour servir cette population ?
500 personnes.
Et bien, comment peut-il servir 2,5 --
250 millions de personnes avec 500 employés?
Simplement parce qu'il ne les sert pas.
Il leur offre une plate-forme,
il leur donne quelques règles, il leur donne les outils
et ensuite, il orchestre en quelque sorte la conversation;
il orchestre l'action.
Mais en fait, une grande partie du contenu
est créée par les utilisateurs eux-mêmes.
Et cela crée une sorte d'adhérence
entre la communauté et l'entreprise
ce qui est très très puissant.
La meilleure mesure pour cela: vous entrez dans l'un de ses jeux,
vous créez un personnage
que vous développez tout au long du jeu.
Si, pour quelque raison que ce soit, votre carte de crédit est rejetée,
ou s'il y a n'importe quel autre problème,
vous perdez votre personnage.
Il y a deux options.
Première option: vous créez un nouveau personnage,
en partant de rien, mais avec aucun passif de votre ancien personnage.
Cela coute environ 100 dollars.
Ou bien vous pouvez prendre un avion, vous envoler pour Shanghai
faire la queue dehors devant les bureaux de Shanda --
ceci vous coute probablement 600 ou 700 dollars --
et réclamer votre personnage, récupérer votre historique.
Chaque matin, il y a 600 personnes faisant la queue
devant leurs bureaux
pour réclamer leurs personnages.
C'est ça, une société qui se bâtit sur des communautés,
qui met des outils à disposition de ces communautés
des ressources, des plateformes où ils peuvent partager.
ceci n'est pas open source,
mais c'est très très puissant.
Ainsi, voici un des challenges, je pense,
pour les personnes comme moi,
qui travaillent beaucoup avec le gouvernement.
Si vous êtes une société de jeux,
et que vous avez un million de joueurs,
vous n'avez besoin que d'un pour cent d'entre eux
qui soient co-developpeurs, qui avancent des idées,
et vous avez une main d'œuvre
de 10000 développeurs.
Imaginez que vous puissiez prendre tous les enfants
à l'école en Grande-Bretagne, et qu'un pour cent d'entre eux
soient co-développeurs de l'éducation.
Quelles seraient les ressources disponibles
pour le système éducatif?
Or si vous pouviez avoir un pourcent des patients des hôpitaux
pour être, dans un sens, des co-créateurs de santé.
La raison pour laquelle --
malgré tous les efforts pour les empêcher
pour les entraver, pour les ralentir --
ces modèles ouverts vont commencer à émerger
avec une force incroyable,
c'est parce qu'ils multiplient nos ressources productives.
Et une des causes de cela
est qu'ils transforment des utilisateurs en producteurs;
des consommateurs en designers.
Merci beaucoup.